[Music]
welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday life
I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a professor
of neurobiology and Ophthalmology at
Stanford so Dr huberman is this tenured
professor at Stanford in a neuroscience
and he has an amazing podcast called The
uberman Lab podcast where he teaches
everything about Neuroscience
productivity and how to optimize your
routine for these things and I've been
really following his podcast for about a
year now I would say and I've really
tried to incorporate a lot of things
that he does in his morning routine into
my morning routine but I thought this
day and this week it would be kind of
interesting if I really challenge myself
to follow his morning routine attuity
that according to him should optimize my
productivity and focus and of course his
morning routine is as steeped in
Neuroscience as he says it so I have
really looked up his protocols for an
optimal morning routine and I have
distilled it down into nine things that
he does about every morning such that he
can optimize his Focus so the first
thing is he wakes up between 6 and 6 30
a.m or and he usually wakes before the
alarm then he views a natural light for
10 to 30 minutes every morning he does a
self-generated forward movement Outdoors
or he takes a short walk or a bite right
he hydrates correctly he delays his
caffeine by 90 to 120 minutes after
waking then he does some optimal
exercise which is usually weight
training then he really optimizes for
deep work by focusing for 90 minutes
every day and lastly he eats a big meal
around noon for brain function and or
mood so I really want to follow his
routine today and see if it can help
Neuroscience student like me optimize my
productivity and hopefully you will
learn something that you can add to your
routine and see if I can really follow
this routine and yeah see you the day
before and let's get into it okay sorry
I wanted to give you a quick update
today is the day before the morning
routine and the thing I'm most worried
about I have to to be honest is to delay
my coffee for 90 minutes I'm I don't
think you know how addicted you are
until you cannot have your coffee but
that should maybe be fine so I have
already prepared my lunch for tomorrow
so according to Dr huberman he really
tries to eat a high protein lunch and he
also is of course sponsored by athletic
greens which I am not but I decided to
add a green smoothie as well to keep
into the theme of Dr huberman so yeah
I'm really motivated today but we'll
have to see you tomorrow because putting
in 90 minutes of deep work having a
workout not having coffee and delaying
my lunch I'm not sure but we'll see how
it goes and see you tomorrow morning so
in the morning I woke up at 6 30 which
is fine it's usually not that much
earlier than my normal wake-up time
which is around seven I do have to say I
personally don't really like having a
set wake up time I usually wake up
whenever I want to and if I had a good
night's sleep that's usually around
seven so I I couldn't have coffee at
that morning so I decided to drink a tea
a herbal tea without caffeine of course
because Dr umerman says it's better to
delay your caffeine intake a little bit
I'm not gonna lie this is disrupting the
flow a little bit of what I usually have
in the morning so maybe I am a little
bit addicted but anyway I'm going
outside to cycle to UNI to have my
morning sunlight viewing so every day I
usually cycle to UNI and I think that
does really help to wake me up and then
I decided to have a workout and that day
I decided to do this barbell training
workout which is in line with Dr
huberman's philosophy that we need to do
more weight training and I personally
definitely need to do more weight
training because I usually like to do
yoga and dance but I'm not really that
much into weight training so after
spending time outside Dr uberman does
two 90-minute blocks of concentrated
work or sometimes one and he really says
to remove your phone remove all the
distractions which I really agree with
and I think it's especially in line with
this philosophy of deep work by Carl
Newport and it's really the idea that if
we want to get into these pouts of flow
and deep work we need to have scheduled
blocks in our day where we really allow
for this type of work to happen
so also from the Dr huberman Lab podcast
it is said that solid research shows
that 90 minutes is about the longest
period we can expect to maintain intense
focus and effort towards learning
shoulder bouts are fine but after 90
minutes a take a break the spaced
intense learning bouts of two to three
or more hours apart most people cannot
do more than 270 minutes of intense
learning bouts per day and I personally
really agree with that I see myself that
having longer moments to focus is really
hard and I think people are usually a
little bit too strict for themselves so
I've had a lot of questions asking me
how I'm able to focus for so long but I
think throughout throughout the day I
actually also only have two or three
blocks of 90 minutes that I can really
focus so I usually don't get that much
focused work done I'm just really
intentional about my focused work so I
know I have my first morning block of
focused work and that's usually the
block I can do the best work so I really
try to schedule this block to focus on
coding for example and I don't really
allow anyone to contact me during this
blog or to talk to me during this Vlog
and I think that's kind of what you have
to do when you want to be productive you
have to be really protective of your
time because otherwise before you know
it people will start calling you during
your most focused block and then for me
at least I noticed the entire day can
become quite scattered so yeah really
try to try to implement this in your own
routine and hopefully this goes well
foreign
just arrived at the uni and as you can
see there's no one here yet because it's
still relatively early it's around eight
o'clock right now and yeah I would
really love my coffee right now but I
cannot have fun until about after an
hour so I'm just gonna have some tea I
guess and then what Dr huberman always
does is he does these two Focus blocks
of around 90 minutes he does say
sometimes he only manages one block of
90 minutes but I know myself that I'm
pretty good at working in the morning so
I usually do manage to get two blocks
that I can really do my best work so to
say and I think one of the most
important things here is to really try
to limit distractions so try to look at
your email not look at your phone
um if you have colleagues around with
your noise canceling headphones on that
really works for me and then what I do
is I really try to focus on one task at
a time so that can be a programming task
or in this case I'm trying to finish up
right writing for a paper that's
hopefully coming out soon it's been a
long time coming and we've worked on
this for really long so yeah this is
still the early morning and hopefully it
will go well and see you in a little bit
for lunch I guess bye
so yeah it's now the end of the
afternoon and I really wanted to give an
update of what I think are the benefits
or advantages disadvantages of following
Dr huberman's morning routine so I have
followed his routine for a week I have
just not filmed it because I don't think
showing the same routine every day is
really interesting so I really wanted to
see if I would feel a little bit
different doing some of the things that
he recommends so I think in general I
just had one really bad day in the
middle of the week where I kind of fell
off his routine because I just couldn't
sleep and then if you have to wake up at
6 30 after after a night you couldn't
sleep it's just really hard and I also
think that this in general is not that
good for you because sleep as we know is
one of the most important thing that
that really helps our brain Thrive so to
say so I in general in my life I
wouldn't necessarily be so strict about
waking up every morning at the exact
same time and Dr umerman also says that
he doesn't really follow his routine to
to a t so if he's hungry for example in
the morning he will eat and break his
fast or if he slept really badly he will
be looking out in the morning I think
that's something that after I moved to
the new city where I live now I've kind
of let go so if now lately been working
out a lot in the evenings but I actually
noticed that if I work out in the
morning my whole day just feels a little
bit more energized and one thing that I
would definitely if you haven't
Incorporated it in your morning routine
yet would definitely do is to go outside
in the early morning right after you
wake up I really noticed that for me it
really gives a burst of energy and my
entire day just feels a lot nicer than
if I decide to stay inside that day and
work from home all day and I think that
especially we something we've lost
during lockdown because a lot of us are
working more at home so the chances that
you view the sun early in the morning
are probably a little bit limited but if
you have a few minutes to spare in the
morning I think it would be really good
to go outside just just for a few
minutes to catch that early morning
sunlight so overall I think I would give
his schedule four stars out of five and
I would recommend not to follow his
schedule strictly but just to experiment
with a few things that he does because
like Wim Hof says unless you are willing
to experience new things you'll never
realize your full potential so that was
Dr huberman's routine I'm really curious
if you have someone or an artist or a
neuroscientist that you really admire
and also follow part of their routine I
would love to hear what your morning
routine looks like or if you got
inspired by anyone to add something to
your morning routine so thank you for
watching this video and see you next
time bye